hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's look at
word search this is a pretty good
problem and it's definitely very popular
so we're given a grid
m by n with a bunch of characters or you
could say it's a board
and we're also given a target word and
we want to
look for this word inside of our board
and if we can
find the word we return true if we can't
find the word then we return false
and so within our grid the word can be
constructed
any way but it has to be either
horizontally or
vertically neighboring cells so
basically what we're looking for let's
say this
is our board we're looking for a path
inside of this board where we can move
horizontally right we're moving to the
right
then we go down and then we go to the
left
so this is our path and we
are looking for a word so we're looking
for a path that can make this
word down here you can see in the
example they give us a target word
a b c c e d and that's the word we're
looking for we're looking for a path
and we can find a path with exactly
those characters
therefore we can return true now the
question you're wondering is how can we
figure this out is there a really
efficient algorithm to solve this
problem the answer is
no there's definitely not a super
efficient one we just are going to go
through
the brute force solution and that brute
force solution is going to be
back tracking so basically this problem
is actually pretty intuitive right how
would you solve this problem
in real life if you didn't have any code
well you'd go brute force right
looking let's start at every single cell
so we'd go through every single cell
right let's say this is an e
right it does our word start with an e
no it starts with an a
now we have a c does our word start with
a c nope does our word start with a b
nope does our word start with an a yes
it does so now let's look at all the
neighbors of a and look for our next
destination character our next target
character is b
right so let's look down we don't have a
b over here this is an
s let's look up there's nothing up left
there's nothing left
okay to the right we have a b gray now
the next character we're looking for is
a c
are there any neighboring c's not up
right
what about to the left we can't reuse a
character
so we can't reuse this a but we wouldn't
want to use it anyway but that's
just another detail right we can't reuse
any characters
down here there's an f that's not what
we're looking for but to the right
there's a c
right obviously we can see that and the
next character we're looking for is a
second c
you know we could run through this but
it's mainly just brute force right we're
going through every single position
looking at every single neighbor to see
if it's even possible for us to make
this target word
in this case the answer is obviously yes
we have an e
and we have a d we can finish it up so
in the code we're going to be doing
backtracking so let me
jump into that or rather we're going to
be doing recursive
backtracking so we're going to do this
recursively or in other words we're
going to do this with depth for search
so let's dive right into it so one thing
i like to do with these problems is just
get the dimension so i'm going to get
the number of rows and the number of
columns
so get the length of the board we get
the number of rows
and get the length of the first row and
we get the number of columns
also remember how i said we can't
revisit the same character twice
within our path therefore we're going to
need a variable
or a data structure for our path we're
going to use a set to
add all the current values from our
board
or positions in our board that are
currently within our path
to make sure that we don't revisit the
same position
twice within our path but other than
that
if you've seen any of my backtracking
videos you know i like to follow a
formula so i'm just going to be going
through that right now so i like to
create a nested debt for search function
within
the root or the regular function because
then we don't have to pass
in some of the variables like the board
and the word because this is a nested
function
but we are gonna have to pass in the
position of the board that we're at so
two variables row column for that and
we're gonna have to pass in a third
variable i which is going to tell us the
current
character within our target word that
we're looking for
so if we ever reach the end of the word
or if i
ever equals the last position so if
i if we ever finish the entire word
therefore we know we
found the word therefore we know we can
return true right that's the good case
the other case is what if we go out of
bounds
right out of bounds of the entire board
what if row
is less than zero or column is less than
zero
right or what if row is
greater than or equal to the number of
rows or if column
is greater than or equal to the number
of columns that's also out of bounds so
or let's consider one more case what if
the
board what if the character that we're
at in our word so word at position i
is not equal to the character that we're
at in
our board so board at position row
column
so if this is the case if we're if
basically we found the wrong character
then we also want to return false
and there's one last condition we have
to check what if the character
or or what if the position we're at row
column this tuple what if this
row column position that we're at is
inside
of our path set what does that mean that
means we're visiting
the same position twice within our path
we know
all of these things that i've just
listed all these conditions
are basically invalid if any of these
are true then we have to return false
because you know if we're out of bounds
we return false if we see the same
character twice
we return false if we see a character
that we are not
looking for we also return false okay
but once we're done with that
then we know okay we found a chara we
found the character we're looking for
right so what can we do we can take our
path and
add the current position to it so the
current row column
to our path because we found a character
that we need
so now we're going to be continuing our
recursive depth first search
and so we're going to be looking for the
result
of this depth first search so we're
going to run depth for search right
we're going to run it in
all four adjacent positions so what i'm
going to do is say row plus
1 leave the column the same and add
1 to i we're adding one to i because we
found the character
we are looking for now we're going to
look for the next character right so now
i'm just going to basically
copy and paste this a few times so so i
copy and pasted it four times because
we're going to look at all four of the
adjacent positions so let me just fix
this up so
you probably see what i'm doing but
basically i'm saying row plus one
leave column the same row minus one
leave column the same
column plus one leave row the same and
column minus one
leave row the same so we're looking at
all four horiz
of all four adjacent positions we're
running depth first search
on all of them and if any of them return
true
then our result is gonna return true
remember we only need to find
our target word one single time
so if we ever find that word then we
know we can return true
so i'm gonna go ahead and return that
result
but right before i return that result
i'm going to do a little bit of cleaning
up so i'm going to take our path
variable
and remove from it the position we just
added to the path because we're no
longer
visiting that position right we're
returning from this function called
therefore
we don't have to continue to visit that
position
inside of our path so this depth first
search
of recursive function is always the main
part of the
backtracking problems once we're done
with this function
the only thing left for us to do is
actually brute force go through every
single position in our grid
and run this depth for search function
on it
so that's exactly what i'm going to do
for every single position
every single starting position in our
board i'm gonna run
that first search passing in the row
column
passing in zero for the position of i
because we're always starting at the
beginning of the word
and if we ever return true if this
differ search function ever returns
true i can immediately return true from
our function exists right i can just
return true immediately i don't have to
wait
and if we never return true if this goes
through every position in the board and
we never return true
then i'm gonna have to return false out
here because that means we did not find
the word that we were looking for
so this is the entire function actually
you can tell that it's definitely not
very efficient right
we're running through the entire board
right so what's the time complexity of
that running through the entire board is
going to be
n times m because those are the
dimensions of our board
and that's being multiplied by the debt
first search function right
because we're calling that debt for
search function every single time for
every position in the board so the
question becomes what's the time
complexity of the debt for search
function
well the call stack of that debt for
search function is always going to be
the length of the word right because the
word can only be so long we can only go
through so many
characters for the word so that's going
to be the call stack of it remember
where
though we have four different branches
we're calling the depth first search for
different times so it's really going to
be 4 to the power
of the length of the word that we are
given
so it's going to be something like 4 to
the power of
n where n is the length of the word so
you can see this problem is not very
efficient so let's just clean this
up so this is going to be 4 to the power
of n roughly
right so it's not a very efficient
solution this is the rough time
complexity of the problem so i hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching